are you kidding me or what Monday
October 15th you're either on your knees
on your [__] feet cuz that's as
easy as it gets
uncle Joey here looking dapper on a
Monday morning getting ready to get mine
[__] I don't care what you worried
about all of this that who gives a [__]
it's Monday it's all over the last week
was last week this week is this week and
you're showing up with a shiny dick and
a [__] bag of condoms on lollipop so
I have to win so there's no
misunderstandings pilot the
[__] Bombardier uncle Joey is
here [__] and I brought the
three K my mother three kings I shut up
to Jesus and brought him gifts I'm
showing up with the three kings today
skinny ne and Denny
all of them are [__] killers you
understand me but nothing matters what
it's all about is you [__] and
how you're gonna make it happy today me
I got meetings that little [__] and
jumping up and down
I got acupuncture I got a podcast I
gotta pick my daughter up and [__]
taking the [__] a little martial arts
class but I ain't complaining cuz I'm
alive and that's all that [__]
matters grab your balls salute the flag
and tell them all to suck your dick
it's [__] Monday and you're taking it
back to basics but Joey which what the
[__] idiot be my smart we're gonna start
with the strongest without all these
[__]
this ghost og let me tell you something
I smoked this ghost og and I heard
[__] noises I heard a bunch of
[__] [__] so this is the we for you
and by the way all these weeds are in
urban trees I'm Ventura Boulevard
that'll [__] around there you understand
me tell the cute sister at the counter
uncle Joey sent you and get the party
started number one there were none of
your studio [__] City questions and
[__] how do you micro look when you
going to [__] urban trees you going
there to see the devil if not go to your
raid on a little neighborhood [__]
[__] [__] weed store with a well
this is good last night I heard the lady
say I really want to get high but I
really don't them with it suck a dick
yeah I'm saying if you wanna get high
that is something thing that'll take you
there and bring you back all at one shot
Joey let's park this [__] gotta
finish what's in here for us when it
comes to represent your family nothing
goes to waste it was a great weekend I'm
West Palm Beach if you came out to the
shows I [__] love you know I'm a
[__] animal the Netflix special comes
out October 30th whatever you want to do
and next Tuesday night the 23rd I'm the
[__] opening of the guest book on TBS
and then the following Tuesday 230 it's
on the 30th I got the release on Netflix
and the guest book
you know why we're [__] around that's
why but anyway
no here nor there the only thing that
matters is that we walked out of here
this morning focused ready to get our
dick sucked or better it talked look so
many iron tell them to suck our dick cuz
you know what we're running [__]
things now I understand me
why walk around with the man in the van
when you ain't got no [__] plan we
could run with the King of Swing uncle
[__] Joey here you understand me I'll
be at the store Tuesday night this week
I've got the store Thursday night this
week I'll be able to split there his
name Saturday night this week's of you
[__] coming down come on down
[__] get ready to get your
[__] world rocked
it's Monday tip top Magoo across the
[__] board if you didn't eat your
wife's ass over breakfast this morning
you [__] up let's keep smoking this
[__] more smoking less talking uncle
Joey and I'm saying more smoking less
talk
[Music]
this reef is too [__] strong but I
don't give a [__] jack so but October is
in full effect is halfway done no sweets
no [__] alcohol for uncle Joey just
straight-up protein [__] weights and
everything else that comes in between
that wasn't I didn't give up no weed I
don't need to give up nothing to be a
part of nothing you know I'm saying it
as a matter of fact I had a partner I'm
friends with everybody what I'm gonna
get an envelope from an organization
that I'm a part of something but until
then I run [__] solo like the [__]
Eagle you understand me I don't give a
[__] jack you don't see no people around
me I show up with 20 [__] I run
so I walk alone [__]
it's like Campbell's cream of mushroom
soup and I'm saying it never [__]
fails anyway we did the [__] ghost
just my end this usually comes in a
little baggie and I put it in this
bottle cause it's the only bobblehead
but this shit's another 26 percent you
understand me
and about 20 minutes my eyes are gonna
be rolling my [__] head but do I give
a [__] no cuz I'm gonna go out there and
swing then you won't see me I have no
couch watching TV I don't give a [__]
about TV I'm gonna [__] up all I give a
[__] it's how I'm gonna get over to
that's the most important thing that was
a big word when I was growing up getting
over if you listen to Curtis Mayfield in
the 70s he was always getting over we're
getting over today and that's all that
[__] matters nobody could stop here
listen
these [__] think they know you
don't know [__] I don't know [__] they
don't they know me too and look at me if
55 is still swinging dick and I don't
give a [__] jack every dad gets stronger
because every day one more day closer to
the tomb which makes me more [__]
scarier you understand me I don't give a
[__] world and a [__] die so you want
to bring it bring a [__] I'm bringing
it every [__] night on that stage
from nothing like a heart attack on
stage guess what you were there that's
all that matters yeah I was there the
night Joey had a lot of time who gives a
[__]
it means I was laying it all on the
[__] line which was I've been doing
since day [__] one you understand me
you want a life you want stories you
gotta lay it all on the [__] line who
gives a [__] who gives a [__] at the end
of the day just you want a [__] cask
you facing the [__] Lord you got to
give something got on a Monday you don't
say you wanna start the day off right
but you know us we got a podcast tonight
at 8 o'clock we got a podcast Wednesday
night
listen I'm delivering the goods on a
constant if you don't like them or
whatever this flip the [__] channel
what do I give a [__] but me I bazookas
gotta [__] shoot me in the [__] head
you follow me Joey which would be a
beating you're gonna Sparkle right
already
got another [__] number hey I got a
couple [__] numbers here we're going
deep [__] I'm gonna go outside
to see if I see Burt runnin around that
[__] says he's goin for a [__]
run [__] him he'll probably run for the
Starbucks and move on that poor [__]
torch you're kidding there him and Brody
anyway it is what it is Cleveland I'm
coming I'm ready I'm coming with George
Perez gonna [__] that place up Thursday
to 25th 26th and 27th get ready to go
we're gonna [__] this smoke dump in I'm
bringing the weed to Cleveland Brown
smoke on the first game they won this
season I got the same [__] weed they
delivered it to me I'll [__] around jack
even the Cleveland Browns are giving me
[__]
I still have my poker a dent it doubles
as a kebab a spear a [__] [__]
cleaner whatever you need I got a cop
Bob for you oh you know I love this [__]
I love smoking me for my [__] church
for a me on Monday morning just to let
you know I got you man and you got me we
got each other I'm with you you with me
and these punk-ass [__] want to be
with us but [__] them you guys been here
since day one - Jay [__]
all you [__] - Bobby's the low
anguses I know I know I know Cleo
[__] Mookie Spooky's down there
smoking some [__] she's blight in the
tree on fire if I know he's spooky my
girl Debra Hofstra representing up there
and [__] Connecticut let
[__] know you [__] with the
church anyone that smoke some [__]
Aretha
okay so [__] about what's going on or
what happens a political climate I don't
give a [__] [__] and a couple pipes
inside I think it's time to bust out of
I think I broke this pipe on the bottom
I think it just melted you know I'm
saying it happens when you melt the
[__] pipe you know you ain't [__]
around who's behind there was a [__]
Chinese guys stand in Miami of your
blackjack table you win it next thing no
you're losing you look behind a little
Chinese guy behind you're putting the
[__] Chinese my Luke on you don't
ever let the Chinese my loop get hold it
they don't [__] around even Santeria
can't read that [__]
tremendous I already had my [__] my
way watch your breakfast
my little protein shake I wrote a little
bit with the little social media and
there's what it's all about I get to
connect with you [__] for five
minutes who gives a [__] we're just
[__] around cracking stupid jokes but
I'm letting you know one thing you could
do it today pleasure dear neighbor
feeling down lately maybe you don't
think who doesn't [__] what they think
and I tell you what you need to think
you need to think that you're gonna take
a shower wash your feet with [__] soap
out of your balls and go out there with
confidence salute the [__] Flag don't
don't [__] believe the [__] hype
they're all a bunch of [__] jerk
clothes if I would have believed these
jerk-offs I would have been dead at this
point and I'm still here 55 swingin dick
and not caring the [__] with a
five-year-old to boot with us these
[__] people are running out of
[__] juju juice these men they're
running out of sperm what the [__] is
wrong with you what the [__] is wrong
with you got him go back to egg yolks
you gotta beat that [__] hand-me-down
lift some [__] weights and you know
look at yourself in the mirror and say
nobody [__] stop and meet that a
[__]
nobody who you I smoked another boat you
know listen I didn't invite you here to
[__] in you know I want a little I just
wanted a little Bobby hi uncle Joey like
I said you want to Bonnie I'm gonna look
somebody's [__]
get your [__] adrenaline gone for 10
minutes this is the real [__] deal
when we get together we don't go Joe you
with you you get together and get down
you understand when we get down here
hmm that was the meal I was looking for
right there guys I don't look at strains
no I don't give a [__] the names are all
made up anyway it's the [__] power a
punch you follow me I don't give a [__]
about this train that's some [__]
amateurs oh wow I got some looks out
what diesel doesn't like our debt I got
that okay I don't know nothing about
[__] strains that's for little white
kids that read height times yeah I don't
care about strength I care about the
[__] am I going that Aida's ask give me
this [__] that's high and that's it
that's it and that's that
it's Monday you know what you need to do
nobody's got tell you everybody gotta go
to a psychiatrist or psychotherapist my
life together you know how to do it look
at yourself in the mirror do 22 push-ups
get that notebook out set up a [__]
plan write some goals and then stick to
them [__] with anybody else thanks
because at the end of the day you're
gonna die by yourself [__]
always remember that you die by yourself
I don't give a [__] what anybody thinks
I spoke my brief I polished my helmet I
do the best I can and that's all that
[__] matters I'm telling you to do
the same there's some bad [__]
without you [__] I have a God
so I'm we cheer with me and the rest of
them wanna [__] suck a dick that's the
saying of the day but we got to finish
this [__] bowl because of not what
what will they say yeah I'm saying what
what they say we put together like four
[__] bowls here in ten minutes
whether you're in or out
or you ain't nuttin here this is all for
the [__] head people who were heads
I'm gonna be heads till they put us in
the [__] grave where the best [__]
big we don't want to nobody we just want
to refill we sit there like the three
[__] monkeys and oh yeah
if you came out to West Palm Beach
[__] on me mother Mary theory I mean
only Botanica horny Raya make it oh yeah
it's a rule
it's of Wegmans lollipop only K so I
missing the mechanic and my mama
repeating how I am with all the yo-yo
even wasn't easy mechanic polio battler
ayah by weight they didn't get my mother
ah bingo and that's it why [__] around
I'll see you guys tonight
eight o'clock tip-top [__] my
government but they could all suck your
dick at the other day you're running
this [__] party